not going to talk about basketball
nothing's uh happened with our team in
the last six hours
we're going to start the same way
tonight
any basketball questions don't matter
since we left shoot around 14 children
were killed 400 miles from here
and a teacher
and in the last 10 days we've had
elderly black people killed in a
supermarket
in buffalo we've had asian church-goers
killed
in southern california and now we have
children murdered at school
when are we going to do something
i'm tired i'm i'm so tired of getting up
here and offering condolences to
to the
devastated families that are out there
i'm so tired of the excuse i'm sorry i'm
tired of the moments of silence
enough
there's 50 senators
right now who refuse to vote on hr8
which is a background check rule that
the house passed a couple years ago it's
been sitting there for two years
and there's a reason they won't vote on
it to hold on to power
so i ask you mitch mcconnell i ask all
of you senators who refuse to do
anything about the violence in school
shootings and supermarket shootings i
ask you
are you going to put your own
desire for power ahead of the lives
of our children and our elderly and our
church-goers
because that's what it looks like
it's what we do every week
so
i'm fed up i've had enough
we're going to play the game tonight
but i want every person here every
person listening to this to think about
your own child or grandchild or mother
or father or sister brother how would
you feel if this happened to you today
we can't get numb to this we can't sit
here and just read about it and go well
let's have a moment of silence yeah go
dubs you know
come on mavs let's go
that's what we're going to do we're
going to go play a basketball game
and 50 senators in washington are going
to hold us hostage
do you realize that 90 of americans
regardless of political party want
background check universal background
check 90 of us we are being held hostage
by 50 senators
in washington who refuse to even put it
to a vote despite
what we the american people want
they won't vote on it because they want
to hold on to their own power
it's pathetic i've had enough